it's sad
that people who are trained
in the scientific community to have the
tools to explore this world
to be children to be the most effective
at being children
are the ones that resist being children
the most but there is a
large number of people that
embrace the childlike wonder about the
world
and may not necessarily have the tools
to do it that's the more general public
and so you know i wonder if i could
ask you and talk to you a little bit
about you know
ufo sightings that there's people
you know quote-unquote believers you
know there's hundreds of thousands of
ufo sightings
and you know i've i've you know
consumed some of the things that people
have said
about it and uh one one thing i really
like about it is how
excited they are by the possibility uh
by it's it's almost like this childlike
wonder about the world out there
they're not it's not a fear it's an
excitement
do you think because we're talking about
uh
this extra possibly extraterrestrial
object
that visited that flew by earth do you
think it's possible
that out of those hundreds of thousands
of ufo sightings
one is an actual one or some number
is an actual sighting of a non-human
some alien technology and then we're not
we did not were too close-minded
to uh to look and to see
i think to answer this question we need
better
evidence my starting point
as i said out of modesty is that we are
not particularly interesting
and therefore i would agree with i would
be hard-pressed to imagine that someone
wants to really spy on us
uh so i would think you know as a
starting point that
we don't deserve attention and we
shouldn't expect
someone but who knows now the problem
that i have with ufo citing reports
is that you know 50 years ago there were
some reports of fuzzy
images you know sorcerer-like things
by now our technologies are much better
our cameras are much
more sensitive these fuzzy images should
have turned into crisp
clear images of things that we are
confident about
and they haven't turned that way it's
always on the borderline of
believability
and because of that i believe that it
might be most likely
artifacts of our instruments or some
natural phenomena
that we are unable to understand now of
course the reason you should you need
you must
examine those if for example pilots
report about them
or uh the military finds evidence for
them
is because it may pose the national
security threat if another country has
technologies
that we don't know about and they're
spying on us we need to know about it
and therefore we should examine
everything that looks unusual
but to associate it with an alien
life is a little too far for me
until we have evidence that stands up to
the level of scientific
credence you know that that we are a
hundred percent sure
that you know from multiple detectors
and you know
through a scientific process now again
if the scientific community shies away
from these reports
we will never have that it's like saying
i don't want
to take photographs of something because
i know what it is
then you will never know what it is but
i think if
if some scientist if grants let's put it
this way if funding will be given to
scientists
to follow on some of these reports and
use scientific instruments
that are capable of detecting those
sightings
with much better resolution with much
better information
that'll be great because it will clarify
the matter you know these are not
as you said you know hundreds of
thousands these are not
once-in-a-lifetime events
so it's possible to take scientific
instrumentation
and explore go to the ocean where the
you know someone reported that there are
frequent events that are unusual
and check it out yeah do a scientific
experiment what's the part why not
why only do experiments deep into the
ocean and look at the
ocean oceanography or or do other things
you know we can do scientific
investigation of these
sightings and figure out what what they
mean
uh i'm very much in favor of that uh but
until we have the evidence i would be
doubtful as to what
they actually mean yeah we have to be
humble and uh
and acknowledge that we're not that
interesting it's kind of you you're
making me realize that because it's so
taboo that the people that have the
equipment
uh meaning and when as is talking
everybody has cameras now
but to have a large scale like uh
sensor network that collects
data regularly collects just like we
look at the weather we're collecting
information
and then we can then access that
information when there is reports
and like have it not be a taboo thing
where there's like millions or billions
of dollars funding this effort
that by the way inspires
millions of people this is exactly what
you're talking about it's like
it's uh the scientific community is
afraid of a topic that inspires millions
of people exactly it's absurd
but if you put blinders on your eyes you
don't see it yeah
right
you